не національну репозитарію
академічних ти xiv вин розрубаний
сем це я треба ним вищих нам чай вищим
початковим за кладами наука вaм встановимо
технічних заслуг для супроводження на
вид них технологій що доза втечі не
це ви явно не академічного плагіату в
наука вих роботах наука вих наука упаду
логічних у це логічних та hinge їх
супротивники
своїх закладі віус тонів атаку з іншого
чим вище його свити
створи не національного репозитарію
академічному тексті поможеш автомати
за ватою процес виявлення
академічного плагіату то запуску трохи
вище навчальний заклад та технічні
чоловіки вас теми для виконання в мох
частими треки є такі 30 дірки та
закони України про шила свиту ціна
звучу і новожиловий етап нашої роботи з
академічної чесності та мета проекту
к'тун не вимагатиме у готових кішки вас
державного бюджету України фінансово не
і з часу не національної репозитарій
академічних текстів плану та з тут на
цієї у мішок завалено обсі у бюджетних
примарних віддав перевагу їх міністерству
нація ерік проекту хто хова джину бісів
важливий вид голосу так його умовляння не
на комітеті
і частий на зал важливий як буллой вид
мінюсту ворогів вони част кого кросу
і трьома ти таку я про позиції Петро і
мати
512 німа за подання рішення прийнято.